♪
ANCHOR: HELLO AGAIN FROM
DOWNTOWN CLEVELAND.
REPUBLICANS ARE GATHERING AHEAD
OF THEIR CONVENTION NEXT WEEK.
AND WE HAVE A NEW BLOOMBERG
POLITICS ITEM WITH SOME
SURPRISING AND IMPORTANT RESULTS
ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON AND DONALD
TRUMP AND HOW THEY ARE DOING A
MONTH COLLEGE EDUCATED VOTERS.
FIRST, A TRIPTYCH OF THE NEWS
STORIES PRINT ONE, DEMOCRATIC
UNITY IN THE NORTH, AND ANOTHER,
ABOUT THE MIDWEST, BUT WE BEGIN
IN THE SOUTH, PACIFIC LEAGUE IN
ALICE, PRESIDENT OBAMA GIVING
AND EMOTIONAL AND SPIRITUALLY
SEARCHING SPEECH AT THE MEMORIAL
SERVICE FOR THE FIVE POLICE
OFFICERS SLAUGHTERED BY A LONE
GUNMAN IN THE BIG "D" LAST WEEK,
FINDING GROUNDS FOR OPTIMISM
AMID THE DEEP DESPAIR, AND THEY
CALLED FOR UNITY AND
RECONCILIATION.
PRESIDENT OBAMA: I'M HERE TO
INSIST THAT WE ARE NOT AS
DIVIDED AS WE SEEM, AND I KNOW
THAT BECAUSE I KNOW AMERICA.
I KNOW HOW FAR WE HAVE, AGAINST
THESE.
PRESIDENT BUSH: WE RECOGNIZE
THAT WE ARE BROTHERS AND
SISTERS, SHARING THE SAME BRIEF
MOMENT ON EARTH AND OWING EACH
OTHER THE LOYALTY OF OUR SHARED
HUMANITY.
ANCHOR: MARKET, WE WILL PLACE A
MORE EXTENDED EXCERPTS FROM THE
DALLAS SITUATION IN A MINUTE,
BUT FIRST, ABOUT THIS EVENT
TODAY.
WHAT STRUCK YOU THE MOST?
MARK: THESE ARE TWO GUYS WHO DID
THIS BEFORE, AND I THOUGHT THEY
WERE EXTRA ORDINARY.
SO MUCH CONFLICT, AND A
BEAUTIFUL JOB.
SOMEWHAT REMARKABLE, AND WHERE
THE OPTIMISM CAN COME FROM.
JOHN: I AGREE.
IT WAS GOOD TO SEE GEORGE W.
BUSH, AND THIS IS A HORRIBLE
THROUGH LINE THROUGH HIS
PRESIDENCY, THE SHOOTINGS, THE
MASS SHOOTINGS IN SOME CASES,
INDIVIDUAL SHOOTINGS AND OTHER
CASES.
THERE ARE TOO MANY OF THESE
THINGS.
AS GRIM AS IT IS, HIS ABILITY TO
CALL ON SCRIPTURE AND SPEAK
LANGUAGE OF SPIRITUALITY, VERY
POWERFUL.
IT WAS VERY POWERFUL LAST SUMMER
WHEN HE DID IT IN CHARLESTON,
VERY POWERFUL WHEN HE DID IT
AGAIN TODAY.
MARK: REMARKABLE.
AND THIS HAD POWER.
ALSO POWER OF THE WHOLE TABLEAU
OF RACES, RELIGIONS, PARTIES UP
THERE.
I AM SURE THE WHOLE NATION
FOCUSED AND PAID ATTENTION, BUT
MY INSTINCT, AT LEAST, WHAT
EVERYONE WOULD HAVE WATCHED, IS
GOING TO HAVE A LOT OF GOOD
FEELING AFTER THE HARD WEEK THAT
THEY HAVE HAD.
JOHN: YES, AND IT IS NO DIS TO
PRESIDENT BUSH TO SAY THE
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S SPEECH IS
IMPORTANT.
THE FIRST AFRICAN-AMERICAN
PRESIDENT, HE TALKED IN SUCH A
POWERFUL WAY.
THE WHITE CONSTITUENCIES THAT HE
KNEW TO ADDRESS AND TO THE BLACK
CONSTITUENCIES, ASKING FOR BOTH
SIDES TO TRY TO EMPHASIZE WITH
THE OTHER.
HE GETS CRITICISM FROM THE RIGHT
OR TRYING TO FOCUS ON POLICE
BRUTALITY, AND HE GETS CRITICISM
ELSEWHERE.
AND IT WAS JUST ABOUT PERFECT.
MARK: I SAW A LOT OF
CONSERVATIVES PRAISING THE
PRESIDENT.
AND I THOUGHT THIS IS GREAT.
AND I THOUGHT THIS WAS A GOOD
DAY TO PUT THIS ASIDE.
TO SEE BOTH PRESIDENTS UP THERE,
AND OUR SECOND BIG STORY HAS
MORE TO DO WITH POLITICS, AND
THIS IS A RATHER UNAMBIGUOUS
ENDORSEMENT OF HILLARY CLINTON
OUT ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL TODAY
BEFORE HUGGING HIS COMPETITOR,
AND THEN CLINTON PAID THIS BACK.
♪
MR. SANDERS: HILLARY CLINTON
UNDERSTANDS THAT WE MUST FIX THE
ECONOMY IN AMERICA THAT IS
RIGGED AND THAT SENDS ALMOST ALL
OF THE NEW WEALTH TO THE TOP 1%.
HILLARY
CLINTON WILL MAKE AN OUTG
PRESIDENT, AND I AM PROUD TO
STAND WITH HER.
X IT IS A PRIVILEGE TO BE HERE
WITH A SENATOR SANDERS, BEING
HERE WITH HIM IN NEW HAMPSHIRE,
I KNOW THIS IS AN ENJOYABLE
ELECTION, NOW THAT WE ARE ON THE
SAME SIDE.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT, WE ARE
STRONGER TOGETHER.
AND, THROUGHOUT THIS CAMPAIGN,
SENATOR SANDERS HAS BROUGHT
PEOPLE OFF THE SIDELINES AND
INTO THE POLITICAL PROCESS.
HE HAS ENERGIZED AND INSPIRED A
GENERATION OF YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
CARE DEEPLY ABOUT OUR COUNTRY.
AND, ARE BUILDING A MOVEMENT
THAT IS BIGGER THAN ONE
CANDIDATE OR ONE CAMPAIGN.
SO THANK YOU, THANK YOU, BERNIE,
FOR YOUR ENDORSEMENT, BUT MORE
THAN THAT, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LIFETIME OF FIGHTING INJUSTICE.
I AM PROUD TO BE FIGHTING
ALONGSIDE YOU.
WE HAD OUR $27 DONATIONS, AS
WELL.
MARK: JOHN, FROM THE USE OF THE
SPRINGSTEEN SONG, AND HILLARY
CLINTON MENTIONING AND PRAISING
JANE SANDERS, COULD THIS EVENT
HAVE GONE ANY BETTER FROM THE
CAP -- THE POINT OF VIEW OF THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN?
JOHN: MAY HAVE BEEN BETTER IF
PROTESTERS DID NOT HAVE SIGNS
THAT SAID, DO NOT VOTE FOR
HILLARY.
EVEN IN AN EVENT LIKE THIS,
THERE IS RESISTANCE.
BERNIE SANDERS COULD NOT HAVE
DONE BETTER.
WHAT HE DOES AFTER THIS EVENT
MATTERS A LOT.
BUT IT WAS VERY GOOD FROM
HILLARY CLINTON'S POINT OF VIEW.
HOW MANY OF THEM WILL END UP
WITH HILLARY CLINTON IS THE BIG
QUESTION.
MARK: HE VERY CLEVERLY TALKED TO
HIS SUPPORTERS, WHERE THERE WAS
OVERLAP WITH HILLARY CLINTON.
ANDY HEADED OUT ANY AREAS WHERE
THERE IS DISAGREEMENT.
I THOUGHT HE WAS WARM TO HER.
I DO AGREE IT WILL BE HARD TO
BRING ALL SUPPORTERS ALONG.
I WAS CURIOUS TO SEE WHAT HE
WOULD DO WITH THE MAILING LIST.
IT WILL DO MORE WITH BROTHERLY
AND SISTERLY LOVE.
JOHN: THE HEADLINE SAYS, CLINTON
GETS ENDORSEMENT FROM SANDERS,
UNIFYING PARTY.
, SAYING, HOPING TO UNIFY PARTY.
I THOUGHT THEY WOULD BOTH LIKE A
LITTLE TIME TO GET IT TOGETHER.
AFTER TODAY, THEY GO FORWARD.
THAT IS ANOTHER BIG QUESTION.
IS THIS JUST A ONE-TIME THING
FOR BERNIE SANDERS, OR TO THE
FIGHT METAPHORICALLY AT
CLINTON'S SIDE.
IF HE DOES THAT, I THINK HE HAS
A CHANCE OF PULLING IT ALL
TOGETHER.
MARK: THEY'RE SAYING SHE AGREES
WITH THE DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISTS.
JOHN: WE WILL HEAR FROM SOME OF
THE SPEECHES TODAY AFTER THIS.
♪
OWN WORDS HAVE BEEN.
>> WE KNOW THE OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY OF POLICE OFFICERS DO
AN INCREDIBLY HARD AND DANGEROUS
JOB, FAIRLY AND PROFESSIONALLY.
THEY DESERVE OUR RESPECT.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT CENTURIES OF
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION, OF
SLAVERY, AND SUBJUGATION, AND
JIM CROW, THEY DID NOT SIMPLY
BANISH WITH THE END OF LAWFUL
SEGREGATION, AND IF WE CANNOT
EVEN TALK ABOUT THESE THINGS, IF
WE CANNOT TALK HONESTLY AND
OPENLY, NOT JUST IN THE COMFORT
OF OUR OWN SERVICE, BUT WITH
THOSE THAT LOOK DIFFERENT THAN
US, OR BRING A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE, THEN WE WILL NEVER
BREAK THIS DANGEROUS CYCLE.
WITH AN OPEN HEART, WE CAN WORRY
LESS ABOUT WHICH SIDE IS BEEN
WRONGED, AND MORE ABOUT JOINING
SIDES TO DO RIGHT.
JOHN: MARGARET, IT STRIKES ME
THAT THE DEGREE OF DIFFICULTY
WAS VERY HIGH FOR PRESIDENT
OBAMA.
HE HAS DONE A LOT OF SPEECHES
LIKE THIS.
RATHER THAN JUST TALKING ABOUT A
SITUATION WHERE THERE WAS A
WHITE SHOOTER WITH BLACK
VICTIMS, OR A BLACK SHOOTER WITH
WHITE VICTIMS, HE HAD TO
BASICALLY TALKED ABOUT
COMMUNITIES, AND TALK ABOUT BOTH
DYNAMICS HERE.
JUST TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THAT.
>> THIS HAS BEEN THE CENTRAL
CHALLENGE OF LAST WEEK, A
COMPOUNDED SERIES OF TRAGEDIES.
FROM LOUISIANA AND MINNESOTA, TO
THE SHOOTING IN DALLAS WHICH
COMPLETELY OVERTOOK THOSE TWO
EVENTS.
AND THEY WERE CONNECTED IN THE
SENSE THAT THE SHOOTER IN DALLAS
WAS ANGRY ABOUT POLICE, RACIAL
MISTREATMENT OF POLICE.
BUT, FOR THE PRESIDENT, IT IS
BEEN A REAL STRUGGLE TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO KEEP THE FOCUS ON
RACIAL DISPARITIES AND POLICING
WHILE DRAWING A CLEAR LINE IN
THAT WHAT HAPPENED IN DALLAS IS
COMPLETELY UNACCEPTABLE, BUT
THERE IS AN EXPLANATION OF THIS
ANGER BUT ALSO CANNOT BE
IGNORED.
TO HEAR THE PRESIDENT INVOKED BY
NAME THE POLITICAL MOVEMENT,
BLACK LIVES MATTER IN THE MIDDLE
OF THIS PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN
WAS -- I THINK HE PINED AFTER
HOW TO MAKE THESE LASTING POINTS
ABOUT HOW HE HOPES THAT THEY CAN
TRY TO PUT THEMSELVES IN THE
SHOES OF WHAT BLACK AMERICANS
EXPERIENCE WITHOUT BEING AN
APOLOGIST FOR VIOLENCE THAT IS
COMPLETELY OUT OF BOUNDS.
IT IS DIFFERENT THAN THAT SPEECH
IN CHARLESTON.
A YEAR AGO, THAT WAS MUCH MORE
OBAMA SPEAKING FROM THE HEART,
HE HAD THE ROBES FLOWING BEHIND
THEM.
TODAY WAS THE DALLAS POLICE
CHIEF TALKING ABOUT STEVIE
WONDER, AND HOW HE USED TO QUOTE
STEVIE WONDER, AND HOW WE WANTED
TO QUOTE THEM TO THE CROWD.
HE WAS A SPEAKING FROM THE
HEART, BUT OBAMA ARGUING FROM
THE BRAIN TODAY.
MARK: MARGARET, WE KNOW THE
PRESIDENT MET WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT LEADERS.
ANY IDEA WHAT HE INTENDS TO DO,
GOING FORWARD ON THESE IMPORTANT
ISSUES THAT AGAIN ARE NOT NEW,
BUT OBVIOUSLY OR THE TOP OF THE
COUNTRY'S AGENDA?
>> THERE IS SO LITTLE TIME FOR
ANY KIND OF ACTION.
YOU DO SEE ECHOES AND EMBERS OF
BIPARTISANSHIP, REPUBLICANS THAT
HAVE TO RUN ANOTHER TERM TO GET
ON AIR FORCE ONE.
IT IS SAFE TO DO THAT IF YOU'RE
GOING TO A MEMORIAL SERVICE, BUT
MUCH MORE RISK YOU -- RISKY.
HE WANTS TO PAVE THE WAY FOR
THESE CONVERSATIONS WHEN HIS
PRESIDENCY IS DONE, FOR THE NEXT
PRESIDENT.
MARK: THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS BEEN
INVOLVED IN ALL OF THESE ISSUES,
HE WAS THERE AGAIN TODAY.
ANY IDEA IF HE WILL HAVE A
SPECIAL ROLE GOING FORWARD TO
DEAL WITH THIS?
>> HE IS BEEN A CREDIBLE FIGURE
IT TO TALK ABOUT THESE ISSUES.
THE MINUTE PRESIDENT OBAMA
STARTS TALKING ABOUT THEM, HE
TURNED AWAY FROM IT.
BIDEN HAS ALWAYS HAD THAT
APPEAL, TO CERTAIN DEMOGRAPHICS
OF THE VOTERS, OLDER, MALE,
WHITE.
AND VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN ALSO
CONTINUES TO HAVE THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS TO THE SENATE.
THE QUESTION IS, IN THE MIDST OF
A PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN, WILL
THERE BE THAT PIVOTAL TURNING
POINT THAT ALLOWS ANY REAL
ACTION OR LEGISLATIVE ACTION
GOING FORWARD?
ABSOLUTELY, WHAT WE SAW WITH JOE
BIDEN DOING THIS ROUND ROBIN OF
NETWORKING REVIEWS, THE WHITE
HOUSE STILL BELIEVES HE CAN PLAY
IN THIS ADMINISTRATION.
MARK: THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
COMING UP, MORE AFTER THESE
WORDS FROM OUR SPONSORS.
♪
MARK: APPARENTLY A NEW NAME ON
HILLARY'S LIST, THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN IS BETTING A RETIRED
FOUR-STAR NAVY ADMIRAL WHO
OVERSIGHT NATO OPERATIONS IN THE
MIDDLE EAST AND ELSEWHERE.
HE IS CURRENTLY THE DEAN AT
TUFTS UNIVERSITY IN
MASSACHUSETTS.
THAT IS A CLINTON DEVELOPMENT,
BUT THE MAN PREDICTED TO PICK
FIRST, IS DONALD J TRUMP.
TRUMP IN AN INTERVIEW SAID HE
WILL DECIDE BETWEEN FIVE RUNNING
MATE CONTENDERS, PLUS SOME
SECRET ONCE HE IS CONSIDERING.
ON THE FAMILIAR LIST, FORMER
HOUSE SPEAKER NEWT GINGRICH.
TODAY, FOX NEWS BROKE OFF WITH
HIM BECAUSE OF -- BECAUSE HE
MIGHT BE ON THE TICKET.
ALSO, RALLY TONIGHT WITH DONALD
TRUMP.
OUR REPORTING TELLS US THAT
GOVERNOR CHRIS CHRISTIE OF NEW
JERSEY WHO CAMPAIGNED WITH HIM
YESTERDAY IS STILL NEAR THE TOP
OF HIS LIST.
IF IT COMES DOWN TO THE GARDEN
STATE VERSUS THE HOOSIER STATE,
WHAT IS THE POLITICAL ARGUMENT
FOR TAKING CHRISTIE OVER PENCE?
JOHN: THEY COMES DOWN TO A
NUMBER OF THINGS.
FIRST, HE IS A MUCH MORE
COMPELLING CANDIDATE AND
CAMPAIGNER THAN MIKE PENCE IS.
IF YOU ARE ASKING FOR A
COMPARATIVE ARGUMENT, THAT IS
WHY.
HE IS THE BEST BRAWLER IN
AMERICAN POLITICS.
WHY NOT GET A STREET FIGHTER.
AND I WILL SAY, THERE ARE ONLY A
COUPLE OF THINGS THAT A VICE
PRESIDENT ACTUALLY NEEDS TO DO.
HE NEEDS TO GIVE A GOOD
CONVENTION SPEECH AND WHEN THE
VICE PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE.
IF YOU ARE TRUMP ASKING WHO IS
MORE LIKELY TO WIN THE DEBATE,
CHRISTIE OR PENCE, YOU'RE
PICKING CHRISTIE.
MARK: IN CONGRESS, THE LEADER OF
THE CONSERVATIVE MOVEMENT, PENCE
PLAYED AT A HIGH LEVEL, BUT NOT
AT THE LEVEL CHRISTIE HAS PLAYED
BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF THE
MEDIA COVERAGE, BECAUSE CHRISTIE
HAS BEEN ON THE COVER OF TIME
MANAGEMENT -- MAGAZINE.
WHAT I'M HEARING ABOUT PENCE ON
THE NEGATIVE SIDE, HE HAS NOT
BEEN THROUGH THE KIND OF FIRE
THAT KRISTI HAS BEEN THROUGH.
IF YOU -- CHRISTIE HAS BEEN
THROUGH.
THEY HAVE BEEN THROUGH
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE NATIONAL FIRE
THEN PENCE HAS.
HE DID NOT PERFORM ALL THAT WELL
IN THE EYES OF MANY PEOPLE.
JOHN: REMEMBER, YOU AND I ARE
BOTH AWARE, WE KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
SOME OF THE STUFF IN CHRISTIE'S
CLOSET, HE HAS BETTING PROBLEMS.
THAT WAS BACK WITH MITT ROMNEY
IN 2012, AND THINGS LIKE BRIDGE
GATE.
WHEN WE SAW HIM RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT HE DID NOT DO WELL IN
THIS NOMINATION FIGHT.
BUT HE DID HAVE SOME GREAT
MOMENTS.
AT ONE POINT DURING THE RACE HE
SAID I HAVE ALREADY BEEN THROUGH
HELL AND THAT, AND I HAVE
SURVIVED.
THAT MAKES ME A DANGEROUS
CANDIDATE.
THAT DID NOT HELP HIM WIN THE
REPUBLICAN NOMINATION, BUT COULD
MAKE HIM A STRONG RUNNING MATE
FOR DONALD TRUMP.
MARK: I WILL SAY, THERE ARE TWO
THINGS ABOUT PENCE WE DID NOT
TALK ABOUT.
HE IS A GRASSROOTS CONSERVATIVE,
A LEGEND IN THE CONSERVATIVE
MOVEMENT.
CHRISTIE IS NOT.
THE OTHER THING, PENCE IS A
POPULIST.
HE VOTED AGAINST THINGS IN
CONGRESS THAT THE ESTABLISHMENT
WAS FOR.
HE IS AN ANTIESTABLISHMENT
FIGURE.
WHILE HE IS KNOWN IN WASHINGTON,
HE ALSO WILL REINFORCE A STRONG
WAY FOR TRUMP.
THE NOTION OF BEING AN OUTSIDER.
WHEN WE COME BACK, HE LOVES HER,
HE LOVES OR NOT.
NOW HE SEEMS TO LOVE HER.
THE ENTIRE HISTORY OF BERNIE
SANDERS AND HILLARY CLINTON'S
RELATIONSHIP AFTER THIS.
♪
>> CLINTON, SANDERS, HERE'S WHAT
HAPPENED.
2016, THEY ARE BACK TO BEING
FRIENDS.
MR. SANDERS: HILLARY CLINTON AND
I DISAGREE ON A NUMBER OF THIS
-- NUMBER OF ISSUES.
>> HE LAUNCHES CAMPAIGN, SAME
THING.
IN MAY, HE'S NOT A THREAT.
BY AUGUST, HE IS.
MS. CLINTON: I VERY RARELY READ
THAT HE IS A SOCIALIST.
>> FIRST DATE, SANDERS DOES
EASY.
REALLY EASY.
MR. SANDERS: THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE SICK AND TIRED OF HEARING
ABOUT IT IN E-MAILS.
>> SHE WINS, HE WINS, MORE OF
THIS AND THIS.
MR. SANDERS: I DON'T BELIEVE SHE
IS QUALIFIED.
LET'S THEY MEET, MAKEUP, BEST
FRIENDS FOREVER.
MARK: JOINING US NOW TO TALK
ABOUT THE CLINTON AND SANDERS
COURTSHIP IS KRISTIN WALKER WHO
IS STILL IMPORT SMITH -- IN
PORTSMOUTH.
WHAT SURPRISED YOU TODAY AT THE
EVENT BETWEEN SANDERS AND
CLINTON?
GUEST: ONE OF THE THINGS I
THOUGHT WAS NOTEWORTHY WAS HE
USED THE WORD I AM GOING TO
ENDORSE SECRETARY CLINTON AND
THEN VOWED TO FIGHT VIGOROUSLY
FOR HER.
I THINK THAT IS SIGNIFICANT AND
BASED ON MY CONVERSATIONS WITH
CLINTON CAMPAIGN OFFICIALS, IT
WAS IT THEY WERE HOPING FOR AND
MORE THAN THEY EXPECTED, SO THEY
THINK IT IS A MAJOR STEP FORWARD
FOR -- FORWARD.
AND PART OF THIS RALLY FELT LIKE
A SANDERS RALLY.
HE TICKED OFF WHAT HE HAD BEEN
WRITING OR AND AREAS WHERE THEY
HAD FOUND COMMON GROUND.
AND THAT $15 MINIMUM WAGE.
NOT EVERYBODY IS READY TO GET ON
BOARD WITH SECRETARY CLINTON.
YOU HAD FOLKS SAYING NEVER
HILLARY, PROTESTERS SHOUTING OUT
AMIDST BOTH OF THEIR REMARKS, SO
THERE WAS A LITTLE BIT OF
EVERYTHING AND A REMINDER THAT
THIS WAS A HARD-FOUGHT PRIMARY
AND SECRETARY CLINTON CLINCHED
THE NOMINATION MORE THAN A MONTH
AGO AND SANDERS WAS NOT READY TO
GET ON BOARD.
ONCE HE HAD THOSE VICTORIES ON
HEALTH CARE, EDUCATION AND THE
MINIMUM WAGE, SHE FELT LIKE SHE
COULD THROW -- HE FELT LIKE HE
COULD THROW HIS FULL WEIGHT
BEHIND HER.
THE QUESTION IS HELD VIGOROUSLY
IS HE GOING TO CAMPAIGN FOR HER.
BASED ON MY CONVERSATIONS, HE IS
PLANNING ON HITTING THE TRAIL
FOR HER AND THEY CONTINUE TO
INSIST THEIR NUMBER ONE PRIORITY
IS TO DEFEAT DONALD TRUMP.
JOHN: MY QUESTION PICKS UP WHERE
YOU ENDED, WHICH IS TALKING
ABOUT WHAT COMES NEXT.
WHAT DOES THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN
EXPECT NOW THAT THEY HAVE AN
ENDORSEMENT PRETTY MUCH THE WAY
THEY WOULD WANT TO GET IT.
WHAT DO THEY HOPE HE CAN DO FOR
THEM BETWEEN NOW AND THE
CONVENTION AND BEYOND.
GUEST: THAT IS THE ALL-IMPORTANT
QUESTION.
I THINK HE WILL GIVE HIM A
SPEAKING ROLE AT THE CONVENTION.
THEY WOULD LIKE TO SEE HIM
CAMPAIGN AS VIGOROUSLY FOR HER
AS SHE DID FOR BARACK OBAMA BACK
IN 2008.
HE IS GOING TO CAMPAIGN
VIGOROUSLY FOR HER, BUT HOW
FREQUENTLY IS HE GOING TO BE OUT
ON THE TRAIL?
THOSE ARE THE DETAILS STILL
GETTING WORK OUT.
HE IS NOT GOING TO FIGHT FOR ANY
MORE VICTORIES.
HE'S HOLDING THE LINE AT WHAT HE
HAS ONESELF ARE FOR HE HAS MADE
THE DECISION AND WE WERE TOLD IT
WAS HIS DECISION NOT TO TRY TO
WIN ANYMORE.
HE GOT ABOUT 80% OF WHAT HE
WANTED IN THE PARTY'S PLAT
NEGOTIATIONS, SO HE CAN GO BACK
TO HIS SUPPORTERS AND SAY WE DID
WIN SOME TANGIBLE THINGS HERE.
HOW FREQUENTLY WILL HE BE ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL?
WE WILL GET THOSE DETAILS IN THE
COMING DAYS.
MARK: WE MENTIONED REPORTING NOW
-- WHAT THE LOGIC OF HILLARY
CLINTON WHO HAS A LOT OF
NATIONAL SECURITY PERSON,
PICKING SEMI-WITH A MILITARY
NONPOLITICAL BACKGROUND?
GUEST: THIS IS A RETIRED
FOUR-STAR ADMIRAL, A FORMER
MEMBER OF NATO, HE IS SOMEONE
WHO COULD HELP TO RALLY MILITARY
VOTERS.
WE ALWAYS KNEW SHE WAS GOING TO
LOOK AT SOME CANDIDATES WHO HAVE
A MILITARY BACKGROUND.
IT DOESN'T MEAN SHE'S NOT
CONSIDERING HIM SERIOUSLY.
SHE WANTS TO HAVE ALL OF HER
OPTIONS ON THE TABLE, BUT
SOMEONE WITH A MILITARY
BACKGROUND WOULD HELP IN SOME OF
THOSE AREAS.
WE ARE HEARING THAT DONALD TRUMP
IS BETTING LIEUTENANT FLYNN AS
HIS VP PICK, SO IT CHECKS ON
THOSE BOXES.
BUT SHE IS SEVERAL DAYS OUT RUM
MAKING THE FINAL DECISION --
SEVERAL DAYS OUT FROM MAKING THE
FINAL.
JOHN: I'M CURIOUS IF YOU HAVE
ANY SENSE OF ANY DETAIL OF WHAT
THE CONVENTION ELEMENT MIGHT
LOOK LIKE?
WHAT KIND OF SPEAKING ROLE
CENTER SANDERS MIGHT HAVE AND
HOW THEY MIGHT PRESENT A UNIFIED
PICTURE OF THE PARTY.
GUEST: I THINK HE IS GOING TO
HAVE A MAJOR SPEAKING ROLE.
ELIZABETH WARREN IS GOING TO
SPEAK IN THE EARLY DAYS OF THE
CONVENTION, I BELIEVE TUESDAY.
SENATOR SANDERS, WE HAVE NOT
THEN EVEN AN EXACT DAY BUT I
THINK YOU WILL HAVE -- WE WILL
HEAR A LOT OF WHAT HE SAID TODAY
AND THIS FULL THROATED
ENDORSEMENT OF HOW HE PLANS TO
FIGHT FOR SECRETARY CLINTON TO
BECOME PRESIDENT.
MARK: THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
, OUR NEW BLOOMBERG POLITICS
WHOLE.
-- UP NEXT, OUR NEW BLOOMBERG
POLITICS PULL.
YOU CAN LISTEN TO US ON THE
RADIO RADIO AT BLOOMBERG 91 --
99.1 FM.
♪
MARK: JOINING US FROM OUR
NATIONS CAPITAL TO WALK US
THROUGH THE NEW RESULTS OF OUR
BRAND-NEW BLOOMBERG POLITICS
NATIONAL SLICE WHOLE IS DOUG
USHER.
EDUCATED FOLKS, WHAT WE FIND?
DOUG: EDUCATED FOLKS ARE
SUPPORTING HILLARY OVER TRUMPED
BY A FAIR MARGIN.
WE HAVE HER WING BY OVER 20
POINTS FOR THE ALONG WHITE -- 20
POINTS.
THAT'S A GROUP THAT IS ONE EVERY
ELECTION SINCE THEY HAVE
MEASURED SUCH THING AND HE IS
TRAILING BY 11 POINTS.
HE MAY BE GIVEN UP A SEGMENT
REPUBLICANS HAVE ALWAYS ONE
THROUGH RECORDED HISTORY.
-- HAVE ALWAYS WON.
MARK: A BREAKDOWN OF DEMOCRATS
AND REPUBLICANS AND HOW THEY ARE
FEELING ABOUT THEIR CANDIDATE?
DOUG: WE SEE A CONSOLIDATED VOTE
RIGHT NOW WITH COLLEGE EDUCATED
THEM ACROSS PORTING HILLARY
CLINTON AS THEIR NOMINEE.
WHEN YOU TAKE A CLOSE LOOK AT
REPUBLICANS AMONG THIS SEGMENT,
YOU DO NOT SEE CONSOLIDATION.
SUPPORT IS AT 75% AND PARTISANS
NEED TO BE SUPPORTING HIM AT 85%
TO WIN OVERALL.
A DEMOGRAPHIC OBAMA WON BY TWO
POINTS, YOU SEE TRUMPED DOWN BY
A FAIR BIT.
THE REAL QUESTION FOR THEM TO BE
CONSIDERING IS NOT WHETHER THEY
CAN MAKE UP A NUMBER AMONG THOSE
THAT ARE NOT COLLEGE GRADUATES,
BUT WHAT CAN THEY DO TO CUT DOWN
THESE NUMBERS BECAUSE IT IS
TROUBLESOME FOR THAT CAMPAIGN.
THEY HAVE TO DO SOMETHING TO
CHANGE THAT DYNAMIC FOR TOP
MARK: IS IT BECAUSE OF TRUMP'S
ISSUE CONDITIONS AS OPPOSED TO
MITT ROMNEY OR STYLE QUESTION
MARK WHAT IS TURNING OFF COLLEGE
EDUCATED REPUBLICANS WHO VOTED
FOR ROMNEY THAT ARE NOW
SUPPORTING CLINTON?
DOUG: I THINK IT IS STYLISTIC
AND I THINK IT IS POLICY.
WE SEE HUGE DIVISIONS IN THE
WHITE ELECTORATE.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHITE MEN AND
WHITE WOMEN, YOU SEE A TYPICAL
GENDER GAP WHERE TRUMP IS
LEADING BY A POINT, BUT AMONG
WHITE WOMEN, HE'S LOSING BY OVER
20 POINTS.
THE REAL THOUGHT IS WHEN YOU
COMPARE IT TO WHEN WE SEE IT IN
THE ELECTORATE OVERALL.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE RESULTS THAT
CAME OUT A WEEK AGO, YOU SEE
WHITE MEN WITHOUT A COLLEGE
DEGREE ARE SUPPORTING TRUMP BY
37%.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHITE WOMEN, THEY
ARE SUPPORTING THEM -- AND
EDUCATION OF 67 POINTS, THAT'S
ON PRESIDENT AND WE HAVE NEVER
SEEN IT BEFORE.
THAT DIVISION IS SOMETHING THEY
ARE MISSING AS THEY LOOK AT
DIVISIONS ACCURATELY ACROSS RACE
AND GENDER, THERE ARE SOME HUGE
FISSURES GOING ON AMONG WHITE
VOTERS THAT I THINK ARE TAKE --
ARE WORTH TAKING A CLOSE LOOK
AT.
MARK: WE TESTED THE THREE PEOPLE
WHO ARE TALKED ABOUT AS RUNNING
MATES, GINGRICH, CHRISTIE AND
PENCE WITH THE COLLEGE EDUCATED
GROUP.
WHAT DID WE FIND THERE?
DOUG: THE QUESTION IS WHAT IS
GOOD FOR TRUMP QUESTION MARK
THERE ARE ONLY TWO PEOPLE ALMOST
AS UNPOPULAR AS DONALD TRUMP AND
THAT IS CHRIS CHRISTIE AND NEWT
GINGRICH.
WHO ARE THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO ARE
JUST AS UNPOPULAR AS HILLARY
CLINTON, THE ANSWER IS CHRIS
CHRISTIE AND NEWT GINGRICH.
THEY HAVE AN APPEAL IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, BUT ARE THEY
GOING TO CONCEDE THIS PART OF
THE ELECTORATE?
CAN THEY WIN BY BUILDING UP
NUMBERS AMONG THE REST OF THE
ELECTORATE?
I THINK THAT IS THREADING A
DIFFICULT NEEDLE BECAUSE IT'S
DIFFICULT TO COMMUNICATE
MESSAGES AROUND TURN OUT.
NEED TO HAVE A HIGH TURNOUT.
ONE WOULD EXPECT TRUMP SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT NUMBERS LIKE THIS TO
SEE WHAT THEY COULD DO MOVING
FORWARD TO BREAK DOWN THESE
DEFICITS BECAUSE THAT'S GOING TO
BE ESSENTIAL TO PUT TOGETHER A
WINNING COALITION.
MARK: THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE WILL HAVE MORE SLICES COMING
UP SOON.
COMING UP NEXT, WE WILL CHECK IN
ON TODAY'S CONVENTION PLANNING
AND COMMITTEE MEETINGS AND
CLEVELAND WHEN WE COME BACK.
JOHN: THE STOP TRUMP MOVEMENT
WILL MAKE IT FINAL STAND HERE IN
CLEVELAND THIS WEEK.
A SUCCESSFUL COUP IS UNLIKELY,
BUT HERE IS ONE WAY IT COULD GO
DOWN.
>> MORE THAN 2400 DELEGATES WILL
BE HERE IN CLEVELAND.
62% ARE BOUND TO VOTE FOR DONALD
TRUMP.
THERE ARE 112 DELEGATES IN THE
ARCANE RULE, MOM HAS AS MANY
VOTES AS CALIFORNIA.
IF THEY FAIL, THE NEXT NUMBER IS
28.
THAT WOULD FORCE A FULL
DELEGATION VOTE.
THAT MEANS A CHAOTIC FLOOR FIGHT
IS WITHIN REACH FOR TRUMP
OPPONENTS.
CAN THEY DO IT?
I WOULD NOT THAT ON IT.
JOHN: JOINING US IS ONE OF THE
COFOUNDERS OF THE ANTI-TRUMP
FREEBIE DELEGATES MOVEMENT.
JOHN MCCORMICK IS WITH US.
BEFORE I GET TO REGINA AND HER
GRAND CONSPIRACY TO THROW THIS
CONVENTION INTO CHAOS, TELL US
WHETHER YOU THINK ANY OF IT IS
LIKELY TO PLAY OUT IN A WAY THAT
WOULD MAKE HER HAPPY.
JOHN: IT'S -- WE WILL KNOW BY
FRIDAY WHEN THE RULES COMMITTEE
FINISHES THEIR BUSINESS AND WE
WILL KNOW IF WE HAVE A MINORITY
REPORT.
JOHN: TELL US WHY YOU STILL HAVE
HOPE.
REGINA: WE HAVE BEEN CONTINUING
TO CONTACT DELEGATES AND WE KNOW
ROUGHLY 70% OF THOSE DO NOT WANT
TO HAVE TO VOTE FOR DONALD
TRUMP.
MANY ARE THERE UNDERDRESSED,
BASICALLY TOLD BY THEIR STATE
POLICIES -- STATE LAWS HOW TO
VOTE.
JOHN: AS A MECHANICAL MATTER,
HAVING LAID OUT WHAT MATTERS,
TELL US HOW YOU WOULD REMOVE --
HOW YOU WOULD MANEUVER YOUR WAY
TO VICTORY.
REGINA: IT WOULD BE TELLING
DELEGATES THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO
VOTE AS THEY CHOOSE AND THAT IS
WHAT IT COMES DOWN TO.
IT IS ALREADY WITHIN THE RULES
TO DO THIS, MANY OF THEM JUST
DON'T REALIZE IT BECAUSE WE HAVE
JUST BEEN HAVING A NOMINEE AND
EVERYONE SAYS YES, LET'S
RUBBERSTAMP THE GUY AND BE DONE
WITH IT.
IT HAS BEEN DECADES SINCE WE
HAVE HAD CONTENTION.
JOHN: YOU DON'T HAVE TO WIN A
BATTLE OF THE RULES COMMITTEE
LEVEL, YOU JUST NEED TO GO INTO
THE CONVENTION NEXT WEEKEND DO
WHAT YOU WANT TO DO?
GUEST: HE RULES HAVE ALREADY
ALLOWED THIS.
IN 1976, DELEGATES IN 246
DIFFERENT INSTANCES HAVE CAST
BALLOTS ACCORDING TO THEIR OWN
CHOICE AND INSISTED THERE VOTES
ARE RECORDED THAT WAY.
GUEST: REALITY IS GOING TO
DEPEND ON THE RULES COMMITTEE.
THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO GET THAT
MINORITY REPORT OUT, THERE'S A
SMALL CHANCE THIS COULD HAPPEN
ON THE FLOOR.
I DO THINK THE MEETINGS ON
THURSDAY AND FRIDAY WILL BE VERY
IMPORTANT IT'S A PRETTY BIG LOT
-- AND IT IS A PRETTY BIG
LONGSHOT.
SOMETHING LIKE THIS WOULD BE
ASTRONOMICAL FOR RATINGS.
JOHN: A REPORTER OF FOX NEWS
RECENTLY SAID JOHN KASICH COULD
PUT HIMSELF FORWARD AS AN
ALTERNATIVE.
DOES YOUR MOVEMENT NEED AN
ALTERNATIVE TO GENERATE THE KIND
OF MOMENTUM AND PLAUSIBLE
SCENARIO?
DO YOU NEED JOHN KASICH OR
SOMEONE ELSE?
GUEST: IT WOULD HELP SOME OF THE
DELEGATES THAT ARE HESITANT.
IT IS THE UNKNOWN THEY ARE
AFRAID OF.
WHETHER THEY WOULD WANT TO BEEF
PUT FORWARD AND ACCEPT A DRAFT.
JOHN: THAT IS RATHER
TANTALIZING.
WHO WOULD THOSE PEOPLE BE?
GUEST: MY LIPS ARE SEALED.
JOHN: WHY WOULD YOU WANT TO KEEP
THAT SECRET?
>> IT IS WHETHER THEY ARE READY
OR NOT.
JOHN: IS JOHN KASICH LOOKING AT
THAT AS A PLAUSIBLE PATH AND
MARK -- PLAUSIBLE PATH?
GUEST: HOW LONG HE STAYED IN THE
WHEN HE SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN
THERE.
JOHN: WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THESE
DELEGATES, WHO WOULD THEY LIKE
TO BE THE ALTERNATIVE IF THEY
STEP FORWARD?
GUEST: A LOT OF IT -- A LOT OF
IT IS TED CRUZ.
HE HAD THE LARGEST NUMBER OF
DELEGATES OTHER THAN DONALD
TRUMP.
THEY ARE WILLING TO ACCEPT
ANOTHER CANDIDATE BECAUSE THEY
KNOW WE HAVE TO STOP DONALD
TRUMP.
ALTHOUGH TED CRUZ IS A CHOICE OF
MOST OF THEM, THEY ARE WILLING
TO GO FROM ANOTHER -- GO WITH
ANOTHER CANDIDATE.
MARK: IF TRUMP PICKS A CERTAIN
KIND OF RUNNING MATE, SAY HE
PICKS GOVERNOR PENCE, WOULD THAT
DO ANYTHING OR DO A LOT TO UNIFY
THE DELEGATES WHO DO NOT LIKE
AND THAT MUCH?
GUEST: HAVING A CANDIDATE TO
COME FORWARD?
MARK: IF TRUMP PICKS MIKE PENCE
AS HIS RUNNING MATE.
GUEST: I HAVE NOT HEARD ANYONE
IS TALKING ABOUT WHO IT SHOULD
BE.
I HAVEN'T HEARD ANYONE SAY IF IT
WAS GINGRICH IT IS BETTER.
THEY WANT TO REMAIN CANDIDATE
WOULD BE AND WHO DONALD TRUMP
PICKS DOES NOT PLAY INTO THIS AT
ALL.
MARK: THAT SURPRISES ME.
EVERY CONVENTION I HAVE COVERED,
THE DELEGATES ARE RABIDLY
INTERESTED IN WHO THE RUNNING
MATE IS GOING TO BE.
YOU ARE TELLING YOU AND YOUR
ASSOCIATES DON'T CARE WHO TRUMP
PICKS?
GUEST: I THINK IT IS
INTERESTING.
BUT I AM NOT HEARING THAT IS
WHAT SWAY THEM.
POSSIBLY A TED CRUZ OR RUBIO TO
HAVE A LOT OF SUPPORT.
SOMEBODY DONALD TRUMP BRINGS AN
ALREADY HAD THEIR PAST -- HAD A
PASSION IS NOT GOING TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
MARK: WE STILL DON'T HAVE A
SCHEDULE.
ANY IDEA WHY THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
MANAGER STILL PLANNING TO
RELEASE THE PROGRAM?
GUEST: I DID RUN INTO SOME
FAIRLY HIGH-RANKING FOLKS.
THEY SAID THE SCHEDULE IS IN
PLACE AND IT WAS GOING TO
POTENTIALLY HAVE BEEN RELEASED
LAST WEEK BEFORE THE EVENTS IN
DALLAS AND ELSEWHERE TOOK PLACE.
THERE IS A SCHEDULE SOMEWHERE,
BUT IT HAS NOT BEEN RELEASED
YET.
JOHN: GOOD TO HEAR YOU ARE
HANGING OUT IN BARS.
THAT'S FOR THE BEST REPORTING
GOES ON.
WE WILL BE BACK AFTER THESE
WORDS FROM OUR SPONSORS.
♪
JOHN: YOU MAY HAVE NOTICED THAT
HILLARY CLINTON WAS VERY
AGREEABLE DURING BERNIE SANDER''
SPEECH.
THE NOD.
WE TOOK A TALLY.
MR. SANDERS: WHO'S SUPPORT --
JOHN: THAT WAS JUST A FRACTION
OF HER NODS.
WE ARE STILL COUNTING THEM.
NEXT UP, ON BLOOMBERG RADIO,
FIRST WORD ASIA.
COMING UP ON BLOOMBERG WEST --
ON BLOOMBERG TV, "BLOOMBERG WEST
."
SAYONARA.
♪
MARK: I'M MARK CRUMPTON.
WITH BEGIN WITH A CHECK OF YOUR
FIRST WORD NEWS.
PRESIDENT OBAMA TRAVEL TO
DALLAS, TEXAS TODAY WHERE HE MET
WITH THE FAMILIES OF THE FIVE
OFFICERS KILLED IN LAST WEEK'S
AMBUSH.
HE DISCUSSED THE BURDENS PLACED
ON OFFICERS IN THE LINE OF DUTY.
PRESIDENT OBAMA: FROM THE MOMENT
YOU PUT ON THAT UNIFORM, YOU
HAVE ANSWERED A CALL THAT AT ANY
MOMENT, EVEN THE BRIEFEST
INTERACTIONS MAY PUT YOUR LIFE
IN HARM'S WAY.
THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS -- MARK:
THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS HE
CONSIDERS THE ATTACK A RACIALLY
MOTIVATED HATE CRIME.
BERNIE SANDERS HAS ENDORSED
HILLARY CLINTON FOR PRESIDENT.
THE TWO FORMER RIVALS APPEARED
TOGETHER IN NEW HAMPSHIRE TODAY.
THERESA MAY HAS LESS THAN TWO
DAYS TO BUILD A TEAM TO RESCUE
THE U.K. FROM ITS WORST LITTLE
CRISIS IN A DECADE.
SHE REPLACES DAVID CAMERON AS
PRIME MINISTER TOMORROW.
CHINA IS CALLING A LANDMARK
RULING ON THE SOUTH CHINA SEA
NIL AND VOID.
THE HAGUE HAS RULED CHINA HAS NO
RIGHTS TO THE RESOURCES WITHIN
ITS BORDERS.
CHINA CLAIMS TERRITORIAL RIGHTS
TO 80% OF THE SOUTH CHINA SEA.
GLOBAL NEWS 24 HOURS A DAY
POWERED BY 2600 ANALYSTS AND
MORE THAN 100 20 COUNTRIES.
I'M MARK CRUMPTON.
EMILY: I'M EMILY CHANG AND THIS
IS "BLOOMBERG WEST."